former president Trump on his way back
to Florida after being arrested and
charged with 34 felony counts in New
York City
it's a day the Press has been rooting
for
this sitting president can and should be
indicted generally consensus the
president is probably committed
indictable crimes he should have been
indicted D.A could get a ham sandwich
indicted Hey listen
Trump's the Big Mac of this situation
the walls are closing in
you know I gotta tell you I am
unaccustomed to hearing people talk like
that about an individual it's almost
though with Trump all the rules change
it's okay to hate
um um no I'm a guest I'll be fast okay
because I ain't much time right
it is always fascinating to me the news
that breaks when Trump starts rolling
down toward Lower Manhattan and
foxnews.com filed a piece about the
evidence that was found in the Nashville
Killers home we still have not seen the
manifesto on behalf of the FBI they're
in charge of the case but there was
evidence that was made public a bit
earlier today
go ahead uh you know what I don't think
that we're surprised by The Thirst a lot
of it comes from there's a new
generation of journalists out there and
I put that in quotes they want clicks
and nobody gives you attention than
coming up with something that you can
write about or say about Trump look at
our competitors in the last 72 to 96
hours
CNN should probably send fat Alvin a
fruit basket
he doesn't look like he eats fruit but
they should definitely thank him in some
way because he has revived that Network
Harold this is payback on top of payback
on top of payback when I was in Congress
it went after Clinton not like this but
they went after him and each each
presidency it gets worse and worse I
don't think that's the way you talk
about this if the president commits a
crime you should go after him but this
kind of talking I agree with you judge
this is not this is not becoming of a A
system that is based on laws and people
follow laws and people respect laws so I
hope that that all members of the press
show some restraint here it's
frightening it really is I want to Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now